the las vegas real estate market
continues to set records the average
home sale price last month was 420
thousand dollars joe mohler spoke to
industry experts he joins us now live in
the southwest part of town with what
they're saying joe
hey there good evening you two well the
las vegas market continues to boom
people are coming here from out of state
to buy luxury houses in particular it's
part of the market that's really taking
off behind me here are some
multi-million dollar homes there's a lot
more interested in homes like these a
lot more people are trying to get them
and they're not staying on the market
very long
my family was looking for a change of
pace jared bybee and his family moved
from california to this multi-million
dollar home the city is just so full of
growth you do have to take into account
cost of living state income tax it seems
a lot of people who are coming with a
lot of money are finding las vegas
appealing in the last 30 days alone
we've sold 121 properties in the one to
three million dollar range realtor tam
gonzalez says 100 percent of her luxury
buyers are from california the average
price of a home in the valley was 420
thousand dollars more higher-end homes
are pushed into the luxury bracket at a
million bucks the average home over a
million was 1.4 million dollars the
pandemic really made people take a hard
look
not only at their finances at global
economics
at the amenities that they had inside
their house las vegas realtor president
aldo martinez says this will be the most
million dollar home sold in las vegas in
a year already 1343 sales is what i had
uh as of close uh on the 30th of
november
that's double almost triple what we've
averaged normally martinez says there
are a number of reasons we are seeing
the increase in prices we're being
supported by an increase in jobs and
income because of those professional
sports teams we have an influx of buyers
coming in from california we have supply
chain issues and we have limited space
to build on
now back out here live many people
especially first time home buyers are
wondering if this market will slow down
at all both of those experts you just
heard from there say they don't see it
happening anytime soon they expect
prices to continue to rise through 2022.
reporting live in the southwest valley
tonight joe mohler live local now